We all know that global warming
is perhaps the biggest threat
facing humanity
over the next 50 years,
but it's not all bad news
according to Yahoo.
According to a recent study,
rising temperatures
will actually be good
for getting folks in
North Dakota out of the house.
You never even thought
about that part of it.
-(applause and cheering)
-We never even thought about it.
You, selfish,
underwater Hawaiians,
it's not all about you
all of the time!
ORLANDO JONES:
Yeah.
-What about North Dakota?
-Yeah.
For some people,
global warming is a good thing.
There are at least
40 meth-addicted frackers
and a dozen or so
buffalo veterinarians
who stand to benefit
from it being a little nicer
outside for once.
-So maybe open your (bleep)
minds... -(applause, cheering)
...and think of some of the
benefits of global warming.
I mean sure, sure, the mosquito
population will skyrocket
and give most of the southern
hemisphere super Ebola,
but for a lucky few, they'll get
to sit out on their porch
on a balmy February night
in North Dakota
and get radiated by the sunset
with their pet polar bear
who now will look like this,
-and great, I say. Fun.
-(laughter, applause)
That's what they look like
when you shave them.
-Every polar bear.
-(cheers and applause)
Polar bears look all scary,
but underneath,
just a little wiener.
-Just...
-(laughter)
So, comedians, I've listed
a couple, but I'm sure there are
a lot more ways to approach this
very optimistically.
What are some other benefits
of global warming?
-Orlan... I'm sorry. Nimesh.
-Donald Trump
will spend his winters
in Swamp Mar-a-Lago.
-HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
Very good. -(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-Orlando.
Well, if it's hot as balls,
we know nudist colonies
are gonna be lit.
-HARDWICK: All right. Points.
-(laughter) -Yeah.
-Very good. -Lit!
-(applause and cheering)
-Arden.
-Um, it'll only
take 15 minutes to fly
from coast to coast, Chris.
-HARDWICK: Yes.
-(laughter)
-Points.
-Yes! -Finally.
In-flight movie's
just gonna be a clip
-of the Cash Me Outside Girl.
-HARDWICK: Nope. -(laughter)